(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
- We're back, with Stains for Strahan.
Zoom got disconnected!
Oh my gosh, Michael,
you drink your coffee
and your green juice,
I'm thinking you drink it like
Robert Hays in "Airplane!",
when he's like.
(audience laughing)
So, this is the green juice right here.
All right. You can see it
sort of looks like dribble.
And then we have the
remnants of a coffee stain.
You don't want this on your jacket.
You came to the right place.
All right, I am gonna go, ooh.
Putting your hands in warm water
is just the oddest sensation.
(water trickling)
All right,
so I'm gonna get the warm water,
and I'm gonna just start getting
just a little bit of wetness in there.
Yep, there we go.
I just want a little water.
And what I want that water for,
is I just want the moisture,
because I'm gonna go with
a little of an old classic,
my Dr. Bronner's Baby Mild.
They have every kind of
like scent in the world,
but I'm going to go
with a clear soap here.
Because what I want is
an undyed viscosity.
I do not want foam right now.
I want this soap to go into the fiber.
Then, ladies, you might
recognize this, it's a buff puff.
But what I have here again,
is there's no dye in this.
So I do not want the dye to
go into the jacket, all right?
I have to say if one day I
could be the master of anything,
well, first it would be, you know,
raising my daughters properly.
I'd like to be that kind of master.
But second in line, second
in line, would be stains.
That's right.
(audience laughing)
The fabric actually has,
and is treated with,
some type of wicking,
so I'm impressed you
even got a stain on this,
in the first place.
Because this is not a
porous fiber, all right?
This is literally like foolproof.
So, well done, sir,
in literally protecting
those that you dress.
(audience laughing)
All right,
now I'm actually gonna
go in the cold water,
'cause it doesn't have any soap.
And I'm just gonna pat, pat, pat.
Because ironically, if I
wipe it with the paper towel,
you're gonna get little
cheese curds of paper towel,
and we don't want that.
No. No, no, no, we don't.
Now, see? It already started to happen.
It's like paper cottage
cheese, that's not soap.
I used the wrong material. I knew it.
Sometimes I just do it
to myself, you know.
It's like, amateur hour over here.
I know not to rub with a paper towel!
(audience laughing)
You need a washcloth for this.
All right, now, this stain is
gone, but the wetness remains.
Cindy!
Bring me the dryer!
(audience laughing)
Yes, a stinger.
(screaming)
(audience laughing)
(air whooshing)
(screaming)
(audience laughing)
(gasping)
(exhaling)
(audience laughing)
Come on! Don't go into the light!
Clear!
(air whooshing)
(screaming)
It's alive!
(audience laughing)
(air whooshing)
(screaming)
All right.
This is wet, but it's clean.
(audience cheering)
And when I get a stinger
that works, I will prove it,
and I will stay here until every fiber
on this beautiful, wicked,
hard-to-penetrate fabric, is dry.
(audience laughing)
Remember,
Collection by Michael
Strahan is available online,
and now in select Men's
Wearhouse stores, nationwide.
And MSX by Michael Strahan
for NFL is also available on,
msxbymichaelstrahan.com
#giftguide, by the way.
One for yourself and one for others,
what a great gift for the holidays.
We're almost out of time, but guess what?
So is Michael Strahan. He's back, too.
Hi, Michael!
- Hey, Drew.
- We lost you a little earlier,
but it actually all worked out perfectly,
and now you're in a new location,
for a better connection.
- Yes, I am.
I am actually at home for
a much better connection.
- What do you think?
- You know what? Whoa!
You know,
I was watching with Jamie,
and you said you're
skilled in the kitchen,
but your skills to getting a
stain out are unbelievable.
Wow, looks incredible.
(audience applauding)
- Well, Michael, I really
wanted to impress you.
You are someone I truly admire,
and just like, I think you're so rad,
and I had to like, get this right for you.
I was really feeling a lot of pressure.
And your Collection by Michael Strahan,
that's now available at Men's Wearhouses,
stores nationwide.
Oh, and the
collectionbymichaelstrahan.com
and MSX by Michael Strahan for NFL,
is available on
msxbymichaelstrahan.com
And I love this jacket,
and it let me do my thing,
- So thank you.
- Well done.
- And I love you, Michael Strahan.
- I love you,
and I'm just so happy you
allowed me on your show.
And, great job. You know what?
If you get a stain on it, just call Drew.
Look up this segment, she's
got you covered, everybody.
(upbeat music)